في السعوديون اليوم وكل عام بذكرى يوم
التاسيس الذي يوافق الثاني والعشرين من
فبراير يوثقوا هذا اليوم رحله الدول
السعوديه الثلاث طوال طوال ثلاثه قرون
وصولا الى اليوم الذي نعيش فيه حكم الدوله
السعوديه الثالثه الزميل احمد الهادي
يعرفون اكثر على يوم التاسيس في العرض
التالي
ذكرى سنويه يحييها السعوديون كل عام
الاحتفاء بالثاني والعشرين من فبراير
باعتباره يوم تاسيس الدوله السعوديه على
يد الامام محمد بن سعود في العام
1139 للهجره اي
1727 للميلاد الامام محمد بن سعود
مشاهدينا بدا رحله التاسيس من الدرعيه
الواقع على ضفاف وادي حنيفه حيث وحد شطيها
رغبه في منحها مزيد من الاستقرار
باعتبارها واقعه على احد اهم طرق التجاره
قديما ليعمل امام محمد بن سعود على نشر
الاستقرار في المنطقه كما انطلقت تحت
قيادته حملات لتوحيد معظم منطقه نجد سنوات
تاسيس الاولى شهدت ايضا جهدا كبيرا لتامين
طرق الحج والتجاره حتى اصبحت نجد منطقه
امنه تماما للمارين عبرها سواء الحجاج
كانوا او قوافل بالاضافه الى تنظيم
العلاقات مع القبائل وتنظيم الشؤون
الاقتصاديه للدوله
بعد تاسيس الدوله بنحو ثمانيه عشر عاما
قدم الى الدرعيه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الوهاب
بناء على دعوه من الامام محمد بن سعود
الذي حماه وناصر دعوته الاصلاحيه ما اسهم
في تقويه الجوانب العلميه والثقافيه
للدوله وتطوير الجانب التعليمي في الجزيره
العربيه
الاعلان عن يوم التاسيس وتحديده باليوم
الثاني والعشرين من فبراير من كل عام يهدف
لوضع تاريخ سياسي دقيق لتاسيس الدوله
والتعريف ببدايتها لكنه لا يلغي رمزيه
الثالث والعشرون من سبتمبر الذي تحتفي فيه
السعوديه كل عام بوصفه يوما وطنيا لتوحيد
الدوره الحديثه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
على يد مؤسسها الملك عبد العزيز
ومن فعاليه اليوان بالرياض ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز ومن مركز اضطراب
الظهران مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
حياكم الله معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
وخلينا نبدا معك يا عبد الرحمن يعني بما
انك محتفي بهذا اليوم
باللباس اعتقد ان شرقاوي بس تقدر عبد
الرحمن تعرفنا عليه اكثر وشرحنا ايضا عن
الصوره خلفك
هلا بك يا نايف طبعا كل عام وانتم بخير
اليوم المنطقه الشرقيه كلها في كل بقعه
هناك احتفال واحتفال بهذا اليوم العظيم
يوم تاسيس هذا الوطن الكبير والخالد
والباقي المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم
انا نايف لابس العقال المقصب ولابس طبعا
الدقله ولابس الثوب المرودن هذا الزي
اجدادنا وابائنا طبعا الى جانب طبعا
المجند الذي كان يلبسه المقاتلين اثناء
المعارك قديما طبعا ومعي البندق
التقليدي الكلاسيكي القديم طبعا اليوم
مركز اثراء هنا في الظهران يقدم برنامج
متنوع وكبير ومميز جدا لزواره سادع زميلي
المصور نصر ياخذ لكم بعض اللقطات ويريكم
الاجواء الاحتفاليه هنا في مركز اثنان
نشاهد الاطفال وهم يحتف ويتزينون بملابس
الوطنيه من كل منطقه نايف يعني الشرقيه
الجنوب المدينه المنوره
نجران الشمال كل الازياء التقليديه
الوطنيه موجوده وحاضره هنا بقوه اليوم
صباحا ايضا كنا في الاحساء في سوق
القيصريه مع الزملاء في برنامج صباح
العربيه وايضا تخيل نايف من الساعه ثمانيه
صباحا الشباب طالعين للشوارع يحتفلون
ويستمتعون بهذه الاجواء خاصه يا نايف انهم
الحكومه اليوم في اجازه رسميه الى جانب
طبعا القطاع الخاص والشركات فالغالبيه في
اجازه ومبسوطين ومستمتعين بالاجواء واليوم
ايضا الحسن حظنا في المنطقه الشرقيه انه
الجو حلو والطقس جدا جدا مناسب نشاهد الان
العرضه السعوديه الشهيره ايضا
هذه الفرقه تقدم العروض منذ الساعه
الرابعه مساء حتى
الساعه العاشره ليلا في مركز اثراء
الثقافي طيب خلينا نروح لصوره اخرى
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض نواف عزيز نواف
مرحبا بك معي ايضا في
هذا القسم من نشره طبعا انت اليوم مو لابس
ملابس التاسيس يا عبد الرحمن بشكل مختلف
طالع لكن قول لي فعاليه الليوان نواف عفوا
فعاليه اللوان ما هي فعاليه اليوم الذي
تحتويه ايضا
نعم نايف بين الابراج الشاهقه في مركز
الملك عبد الله المالي بالرياض انطلقت
فعاليه الليوان للتو وهي تشكل واحده من 14
فعاليه منتشره في مناطق المملكه للاحتفال
في يوم التاسيس وتستمر على مدى ثلاثه ايام
هذه الفعاليه كما سنشاهد الان تعبر عن
التراث والتاريخ للدوله السعوديه منذ
التاسيس حرف يدويه ايضا عمليات اخرى
ومعارض وعروض موسيقيه وفرق جواله ترتدي
الزي السعودي الاصيل كما نشاهد الان خراز
الاحذيه وهو ابو عبد العزيز الخراز اهلا
وسهلا ابو عبد العزيز في البدايه كيف تتم
صناعه الاحذيه قديما باستخدام الجلود طبعا
بعد دبابه الجلود بناخذ
الجلد ونسوي منه المشغولات الجلديه
الاحذيه في مرحله من المراحل نسويها بعدين
تبدا الشنط بعدين تبدا اللي هي المجالد
وبيوت المسدسات والسكاكين هذه كلها
الزوار ماذا على ماذا يتعرفون عند هذه
الزياره المعرض الخاص بك طبعا الزوار يعني
يبحث عن التراث الصراحه يعني في حاجات ما
يعرفوها الان بعد من بعد يعني الكلمه اللي
احنا بنقدمها لهم
والنبذه التعريفيه البسيطه وبياخذوا فكره
حلوه الصراحه كل الشكر لك يا ابو عبد
العزيز اضافه الى وجود العديد من المعارض
الاخرى نايف حياكه السيو كما نشاهد في هذا
المعرض
تتواجد فيه سيده وهي من الاسر المنتجه
والسد يعتبر ايضا يعني متعارف عليه كثيرا
في السعوديه ويروج له خلال الفتره الاخيره
بشكل كبير هذه الفعاليه من قبل وزاره
الثقافه تنظم وكما ذكرت هي في اربعه عشر
منطقه وتستمر على مدى ثلاثه ايام بتنوع
واسع عروض موسيقيه ومعارض تفاعليه اشكركما
جزيل الشكر من الرياض مراسل العربيه نواف
عزيز وكذلك ايضا من مركز اثراب الظهران
كان معنا ايضا مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]